توقع مديره منظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرسوس سقوط مزيد من الوفيات في السودان
جراء نقص الخدمات واشار المسؤول الامميين
في مؤتمر صحفي الى ان ستين في المئه من
المنشات الصحيه في الخرطوم مغلقه وان 16%
فقط من هذه المرافق الصحيه هي التي تقدم
خدماتها للسودانيه
الذين يحاولون الهروب يهدد الانظمه وشبكات
في البلد منذ بدايه الصراع
تاكدت المنظمه من 16 اعتداء على المرافق
الصحيه
المنظمه قلقه
او جراء احتلال احد اطراف النزاع المختبر
المركزي ليس للخبراء امكانيه النفوذ الى
المختبر
معنى من بيروت امانه طرابلسي المتحدثه
الاقليميه للجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر هل
هناك اي اخبار ايجابيه يمكنك ان تخبرين
بها عما يحدث في السودان وعمل الجهات
الصحيه المنظمات الصحيه مثل منظماتكم
مرحبا للاسف الاخبار ليست ايجابيه باتم
معنى الكلمه اخر المستجدات التي وردتنا من
طرف زملائنا في الميدان هو ان اليوم
الخرطوم تشهد هدوء حظر ولكن هذا الهدوء لا
ينطبق على كل المناطق التي تشتد فيها
وتيره العنف لا سيما دارفور اليوم على
سبيل المثال اليوم الهدوء الحذر الذي
شهدته الخرطوم وفر امكانيه للسكان الذين
كانوا عريقين في مختبئين يعني على امتداد
الايام الفارطه من غير اي امدادات مكانتهم
هذا مكانهم هذا الهدوء النسبي من الخروج
من
مناطقائهم للحصول على الامدادات وردتنا
كذلك اخبار بان البعض حاول او حاول الخروج
من الخرطوم للانتماس الامن في مناطق اخرى
ولكن من الجدير الاشاره اللجوء الى اماكن
اخرى او الخروج من الخرطوم يعد صعبا ومعقد
نسبيا بالنسبه للسكان وذلك لان بعض
المناطق التي من الممكن ان يلجا اليها
تخضع لسلطات او لتخضع السيطره مجموعات
مجموعات اخرى مجموعات اخرى منخرطه في
النزاع وبالتالي هذا يعقد عمليه الخروج من
الخرطوم اليوم من الضروره تفضل نعم يعني
هناك اسئله كثيره في الحقيقه احدها يتعلق
بتصريح لمنظمتكم حول سيطره يعني جهه لم
تسموها احد اطراف الصراع على مختبر وان
هذا قد ينذر بكارثه
بيولوجيه اعتقد كان في في تصريح المنظمه
هل يمكن ان ان يعني
تتحدثي معنا اكثر عن هذا الموضوع وما الذي
يعني
على تصريح هو ليس من طرف اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر ولكن ما يمكن ان اشارككم
اشارككم به الان هو ان الوضعيه للوضعيه
حرجه جدا في الخرطوم على مستوى قطاع الصحه
كما ذكرتم حضرتكم يعني جزء كبير من
المؤسسات الصحيه داخل الخرطوم هي غير
قادره اليوم على تلبيه الاحتياجات الصحيه
للسكان وذلك لنفاذ
قرب نفاذ المخزون للادويه والمعدات الطبيه
وكذلك انقطاع المياه والكهرباء مما يجعل
المؤسسات الصحيه غير قادره على استيعاب
العدد الذي يقبر مع مرور كل ساعه للاشخاص
الذين يحتاجون رعايه صحيه استعجاليه
وبالتالي اليوم من الضروره واولويتنا نحن
كلجنا دوليه للصليب الاحمر بان يتم توفير
كل الضمانات الامنيه اللازمه
بما في ذلك الاحترام الكامل للهدنه لكي
نتمكن التحرك اولا ثانيا من من ادخال
المزيد من الامدادات لاسيما الامدادات
الطبيه للمؤسسات الصحيه في كل المناطق
التي تشهد تشهد عنف اليوم داخل السودان لا
سيما الخرطوم
يعني هذه العنايه الصحيه
طرفاء الصراع هم بحاجه لها وليس فقط
المواطنون المدنيون لا ننسى ان هذا الصراع
سوف يخلف للاسف العديد من الجرحى والقتل
ايضا وبالتالي هل انتم على اتصال مع طرفي
الصراع
لتامين قدرتكم على المساعده وما الذي
يقولانه لكم
الحصول على الرعايه الصحيه لمن يحتاجها هو
لا هو ليس حصرا على طرف معين كل من يحتاج
رعايه صحيه يجب ان يتحصل عليها وهذا ما
ينص عليه القانون الدولي الانساني الذي
نعمل على
نعمل على ان يحترمه كل الاطراف الخريطه في
النزاع ليس فقط في السودان ولكن في كل
الاماكن تدخلنا حول العالم نحن وجودنا في
السودان ليس وليد اليوم نحن موجودين وندير
عملياتنا في السودان منذ نهايه السبعينات
وكانت لدينا ولا تزال لدينا خطوط حوار مع
كل الاطراف المنخرطه في النزاع
لهدف اساسي وهو ضمان ان يفهم كل الاطراف
ضروره احترام القانون الدولي الانساني وما
يقتضيه ذلك من حمايه مصالح وحياه
الاشخاص
والمدنيين حمايه البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه
وكذلك حمايه الحيز المخصص للعمل الانساني
ما حدود تواجدكم اذا كان لكم اي وجود
حاليا في السودان
بالتنسيق والعمل مع الهلال الاحمر
السوداني
مع كل شركائنا في الحركه الدوليه للهلال
وصليب الاحمر بما فيهم الهلال الاحمر
السوداني حاليا
فرقنا وطواقمنا لا تزال موجوده في السودان
نحن لم نجلي لم نقوم بعمليات اجلاء
لفرقنا كل الفرق هي موجوده على مكان
ومستعده للتحرك حاله ما تتوفر كل الضمانات
الامنيه اللازمه
لتمكين من القيام بعملنا ومهمتنا في هذا
في هذا الظرف الحساس هل هناك من نصائح
توجهونها للعاملين في القطاع الصحي في هذا
الظرف الحساس لان مؤسستكم لها خبره طويله
في العمل في ظروف من هذا النوع
لا ادري ان ان ممكن ان اشير لما سوف اقول
لك نصائح لها نحن ليس ليس لدي نصائح
استحضرها حاليا ولكن اليوم ما يمكن ان
اقوله بان الوضع حرج وحساس جدا على كل
الاطراف المنخرطه في النزاع وضع الحياه
البشريه وضع المصلحه الانسانيه قبل كل
المصالح اليوم من الضروره ان يتمكن
الفاعلون الانسانيون بما فيهم اللجنه
الدوليه لصليب الاحمر وشركاء الهلال
الاحمر السوداني بان يكون على قدره
بالتحرك وادخال الامدادات ومواد الاغاثه
لكل من يحتاجها في كل مكان بغض النظر عن
من يسيطر عن ذلك المكان نتمنى ذلك شكرا
جزيلا لحديثك الينا من بيروت ايمانه
طرابلسي المتحدث الاقليميه للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر